february 14th is coming up here
valentine's day and you know we don't
want anybody to be lonely
i'm pretty sure she's not even a real
human you know give him like a vfx
makeover
so that way every lady that looks at him
will immediately fall in love
it might require all the resources of
this company to make matt
a suitable tender profile that attracts
all the women
so valentine's day is here i'm not
excited for valentine's day this year
nowhere to go everything's open again it
is last week
i'm not excited for valentine's day
because every day at my house especially
like valentine's day
february 14th is no different
i like to think of how our art can have
a positive impact on the world
february 14th is coming up here
valentine's day there's not a whole lot
of single
yeah everyone here seems like they're
nurse but we're all very high
functioning socialites
and you know we don't want anybody to be
lonely i got a tinder match bro
let me see maybe she's the one i'm
pretty sure she's not even a real human
it's tough out there
matt i've heard whispers through the
grapevine that you know he's out there
he's trying
trying to catch a fish in that big sea
stuff out here in the single life it's
not like you can meet up with people
it's kind of just like
hey let's uh talk and get to know each
other over the internet
and then you know maybe we'll just wait
for a year and if
it's horrible out there dude romance is
dead now
it's challenging it's tough i've spent a
lot of time with my cat
you'll be my valentine right cat
right i mean what are you gonna do well
i was once single
on a valentine's day perhaps more than
one all i can say
is that i wish that there was somebody
in my corner
i think we could help make matt's
valentine's day better i think we could
spruce up his tinder profile you know
give him like a vfx makeover
so that way every lady that looks at him
will immediately fall in love
i think he would really appreciate that
do you think we can spice him up
do we take his pre-existing
tastes and thus potentially double down
on his chances of failure i have a cat
all of my teeth i have a job or
do we i guess impose our own tastes on
it i haven't updated my tinder profile
in a very long time so i have some
pretty old pictures
like this one what if you're like on
tinder it's all like what it's like
pictures and text
it's like instagram you know and
everyone knows that on instagram
all the photos are doctored they're all
fake it's like they're both
using the same form of communication so
why can't we bring
that cool like aspect you see on
instagram of like hyping up your life
hyping up everything about you
doctoring the [ __ ] out all your photos
but using that for your advantage on
tinder
i think that's what he's lacking on his
tinder profile dude pimp my tinder
profile
maybe with like some married men that
have never used tinder before
you guys ever used tinder never have no
but
i know we know all about it yeah we know
what tinder is it's been out for years
like
i think step one here is to get matt am
i getting a promotion you can say that
i'm excited
we have to identify what women want
is it cars is it airplanes is it
lightsabers
probably those three combined i think
women want a guy who's confident
in himself and his own tastes the cooler
the taste the better
what are we doing it might require all
the resources of this company to make
matt
a suitable tender profile that attracts
all the women
what's up guys what's up man how are you
doing oh i'm doing great
could you be doing better we want to
help you how how do you think you could
help we know that there's this thing
called tinder
yeah it's like uber
for girls just like uber for girls
what if we took those pictures and gave
them a vfx makeover
yeah cool look we clearly know what
women like
when i've been on dates and i started
talking about vfx and like after effects
workflows and stuff their eyes totally
blaze over
yeah i convinced their family with me
you know how i did that
vfx i'm
serious my whole family is because of
visual effects she was so impressed with
my visual effects
that she was like yes sam we will now
date wow look it up the movie is called
space dogs
i guess i've been thinking about this
all wrong then if i can get a valentine
for that special day
through the the art and magic of visual
effects with the help of
these two talented individuals well i
will forever be in your debt
sounds good women like vfx what else
goes on our list
what do women want women do women like a
guy who is in touch with his
like inner whatever you know what do
women like about you
what do women like about me do they like
your car no
women like sports cars everyone loves
sports cars that's like a surefire hit
they also love saving the environment oh
i know
exactly what you mean i will say that
one thing that women do like
is the humor is my humor i had whiskey
with dave chappelle once so that's not
even a lie can you do like flips can you
do kicks like pull out a backflip
yeah do you like harry potter i mean no
do you think women like that about you
that you don't like harry potter uh no
a lot of women like harry potter well
can you act like you like harry potter i
can pretend like i like harry potter
yeah harry potter is like
star wars but for for women for women i
also cook
what if i make gordon ramsay cry oh
yes yes yeah
oh i also left out an act of heroism we
need one good act of harassment yeah
there's a lot of fires in california
firefighters saying like
i'm not a firefighter i don't want to
lie to them but handing out water
bottles to firefighters is good
because those firefighters are going to
be dehydrated after all that fire
we got a lot of work to do yeah all
right so let's get to work
making some good vfx i like it i'm doing
eco-friendly matt
i'll do gordon ramsay and firefighters i
guess
also gonna do the harry potter one let's
start taking pictures
find valentine's day can be
a little stressful but i think the guys
are going
a little too far with this women want a
man who's real
who appreciates them and pays attention
and there's no sure
way i think to show that than to have a
nice high quality picture
of matt wearing today's sponsor raycon
earbuds because nothing
says i love you than like a picture of a
man
wearing earbuds i've been married for
six years how do you think i got married
boom here we go okay there's matt
there's our boy i got relatively the
same angle
of his ear and i'm just basically gonna
cut out my ear
put it on his ear boom photo of him
wearing raycons when they see this photo
they're gonna think hey you know what
raycon is disrupting the electronics
industry by designing premium wireless
audio for half the price
not only just from the way they design
their products and price them but also
because they prioritize the consumer
experience and obviously
these earbuds are in black but raycons
come in all
fun colors with a variety of fit options
and
no dangling wires or stems we've got
ourselves in the air boys
now first and foremost we're gonna drop
this down here
so now that i've got the ear cut out
i'll just make a few little tweaks here
blend it shade it raycon has a 45 day
free return policy
one thing that might not be immediately
obvious by looking at this
image is that raycon's not only did they
come in a compact carrying case
they also have six hours of play time
seamless bluetooth pairing
more bass and a more compact design for
a more comfortable
noise isolating fit i'm doing this for
matt he's probably gonna have children
as a result of this image
my work here is done uh it's time to
show matt and uh get back to business
i'm just gonna show you the image and
you tell me if you like it or not okay
i'm not gonna tell you anything and
everything else i've seen so far
yeah it's gonna be great boom we're
gonna go straight into this okay okay
what do you think oh look at those i
mean
it's the raycons man right
did you replace my ear with someone else
hopefully it'll get included along with
the final renders and if you guys are
interested
in getting a pair of raycons for
yourself head on over to
buy raycon dot com slash cord or crew
and you'll get 15
off your purchase that's by raycon.com
core or crew for 15 off your purchase
if i came across a tinder profile with
like a bunch of pictures this elaborate
i'd at least want to talk to him
lower your steering wheel hand matt are
you worried that uh your tinder profile
can be too intimidating for women
yeah it's pretty important to find a
balance where it's like i'm not like too
impressive to wear like okay he's not
like a god or anything i'm gonna take a
picture of matt without a shirt on
rather than like swapping in somebody
else's body i need to be authentic
can't tell a lie here i need to be
truthful so i'm gonna take matt's own
body
and bulk it out a little bit hopefully
he doesn't get mad at us for
making him fall in love too many times
call me old-fashioned
i met my wife in traffic court all right
so for the first shot
i have to do matt yelling at gordon
ramsay first things first i need a
kitchen background
i have matt here and i had gordon
ramsay's head
i grabbed another picture of gordon
ramsay so the neckline and everything
would line up
i stuck the two together and i get this
now his color is way way way off i mean
we can see it's way more red than matte
so
simple fix just apply some color balance
and apply a little hue saturation
tone it down a little bit and a little
bit of curves just to kind of balance
the brightness to
make it match matte it's coming together
but we're still missing a couple more
things
gordon ramsay is right in front of matt
and he should kind of be casting a
shadow on him so i've gone ahead and
i've literally just painted in a shadow
throw in a little bit of color
correction on the suit a little hell's
kitchen episode 32 in the bottom corner
you know what one last thing this could
overall use is maybe just like just a
little punch
the entire image you apply a color grade
to the entire image after you've done
your visual effects kind of marries
everything together just a little bit
oh yes i almost forgot so the picture i
had of gordon ramsay
he wasn't look at that set he's kind of
looking just cool like
you know he's maybe crying but it kind
of looks like he's laughing so i'm gonna
pop this open in photoshop's
liquify feature and they have like a
face of wear part from liquify so i can
turn down the corners of the mouth i can
make the mouth more wide
all those good things that make it look
like gordon ramsay's crying instead of
laughing they also have these neural
filters which can change your expression
they're hilarious but they're pretty
dang janky
you know matt's looking like a little
stern right i'm gonna run through the
neural filter here and boom
now he's like a little less angry he's
got like a little twinkle in his eye
oh you rascal
i forgot what i'm trying to accomplish
with this
and then spectacles all right i'm just
gonna [ __ ] draw them
that's not bad but not quite round
all right wait wait wait wait wait wait
hold on the final touch
the final artist's touch
[Music]
swipe
[Laughter]
it has been a couple hours and i'm
patiently awaiting
my pimped out tinder profile i think sam
and nico have uh a good eye for
tastefulness so i'm sure it's gonna be
it's gonna be perfect
okay moving on matt out trying to help
with the uh
california wildfires bringing some water
to the firefighters
i'm kind of feeling like i need like
just a little more
muscles there you go there's my buff mat
his arms can be
a little bit beefier trying to highlight
his strengths his qualities his wing
muscles here
good pectoral muscles there we go look
at that ripped man just helping those
firefighters
saved done i'm ready valentine's day is
coming up so quickly like we had to get
these out today
but i think we did a pretty good job for
the time we had most importantly i want
to hear from everybody else when you
look at these pictures what does it tell
you about who he is
i want a car that makes me look cool
because it's fast and it goes from vroom
but
it is also eco-friendly so it doesn't
guzzle gas shows that i
care about the environment wow
what
[Laughter]
i see a man of vision a man a man of the
future
to build a car like this first of all
he's probably a billionaire i see a
successful young man who's got a vision
for how he wants to get around in the
future
wow who what says you're a better chef
than when you are one up in gordon
ramsay
look he's so sad this is exactly what i
wanted with
this image what did you do to my face by
the way nico
it doesn't really look like me it
doesn't really look like this
because yeah it's very strange i'm not
sure if the anger
slash like condemning route is really
the direction
that the ladies are gonna want here how
about your sense of humor god
uh i'm very funny so look at me flipping
this prestigious
just some of the best comedians and elon
musk who probably
gave me the the musk wagon aren't you
just
standing with your arm around like joe
rogan and neil
this also shows my athleticism we got
carried out
we got carried away this one is not
appearing on your profile
i'm not even going to explain this
[ __ ] jack water
yes they're dehydrated oh my god that
that's just how i look yeah this is this
is my my vision board
this one definitely needs to go in we
were trying to figure this one out we're
like
i was just like matt do you like harry
potter and he said no i was like but you
have to
i'm saying i don't meet a lot of girls
that are like everybody's
ladies a lot of different types of girls
out there this is like netflix and chill
kind of wrapped up into a single image
yeah you guys want to have a pottermore
yeah
oh it's so inviting it's so warm and
inviting
it's cool that's like i could sit down
and get to know him you know
i like the little scar too and he's got
a cup for you for you
the viewer i made
this true complex things happening in
photoshop and then he decides to draw
those but like everything else is like
magical and whimsical
it's about the magic that's a great
image ultimately
i think you guys really gave me some
great images to work with here so you're
going to upload these tonight
and then in a couple hours you'll be
maxed out with like i think some
connections
yeah yeah i think so i think it's going
to work guys i'm going to take these
photos i'm going to upload them to my
tinder profile
and we'll see what happens maybe i'll
get a valentine's day date
so this is the follow-up this is the
follow-up you're checking in
to see how you changed my life one week
with
my new tinder yeah i think the question
on everybody's mind is
did it work did it work so this is what
happened um
if i go on tinder i'll get like maybe
one or two matches total
and when i put these glorious pictures
on my profile how many i got exactly
zero matches oh no i i got
none zero for the past like four days i
was swiping non-stop
i didn't even discriminate i was just
boom boom boom boom
i found a solution what i did is i
removed one image
i took the beef out of the beef sandwich
so literally i took
away the firefighter shot and then what
happened
and then i started getting matches again
really yes whoa
the big question is did you find a
valentine's date
i did i have a date this weekend what
really legitimately i do
yeah okay yeah do tell
she said i love it the totally real pic
of you making gordon ramsay cry
is my favorite
favorite that was her favorite one oh
she just thought it was funny she
thought they were funny pictures
also i like the fact that she was
sarcastic about it so i guess in some
way i should thank both of you
because you don't have to be around it's
all a day's work
i actually i legitimately thought that
like we would help your profile stand
out and be like this guy's kooky
yeah talk to him but turns out it just
repelled even more people
it felt more concerned now because i
wonder if
now my whole life is a lie did she
really marry me for the vfx
or was it something else
so there you have it we pimped my tinder
profile i don't know how much it
actually helped to be honest
i think the more important thing here is
that you're genuine with people
and the right person is going to come
your way who likes you you know for you
and if you don't have a valentine that's
fine like
valentine's is dumb anyway you're gonna
end up finding the person that is meant
for you
and there's no timer on that you know
there's no there's no date that says you
gotta do it i hope you enjoyed the video
be sure to subscribe smash that like
button and uh comment to let me know
what you think about my profile
did you find me on tinder did you swipe
left you probably did